i'm going to end on a lighter note to  nikolai  because i i know that um danish and i  i literally just released a song in like  six different languages and i love  languages  but i've never spoken one word in danish  i believe so i was wondering if you  could teach me to say something in  danish that's easy  something that's easy any any  preferences anything you want to  know i mean how would i how would i say  like can i could i please have an apple  danish  is that really the word no you say  ken ken yay  for  okay i tried i'm going to learn it and  the next time i'm going to freaking  learn how to say that and it's going to  be so effortless the next time i see you  um and then you better have an apple  danish um okay  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel  please don't make me keep going